Kris Jenner speaks out about Rob
Kardashian and blac Chyna's romance for
the first time exclusively to ET I don't
really know much about their
relationship I think you know there are
definitely friends and and they seem you
know great but I see Rob every single
day and he comes by and he's really
excited about spending time with the
kids because north and st. live with me
so he comes by for that visit rob has
been in a really good place for a while
and he's he wrote me yesterday and said
I just finished my workout what do you
want you know because I was texting
about something business and he was
being playful you know but he's he's
he's on it right now and he's engaged
and I love seeing him you know happy
about what he's doing and he loves his
sock business and we did the relaunch
and he's excited about that so it's shop
Arthur George calm he's got an amazing
website with all his thing and he's just
getting started and I'm proud of him
yeah he's doing good he's you know
trying to manage all the different
things in his life and you know being a
crazy family with a hundred sisters and
it's like it's wild